hello reject nation it's Greg al-baqir
it's John Humphrey over here and you're
right has another this movie is getting
amazing or review it's got like a six
hundred percent yeah baby driver another
trailer out to kill you is the nickname
of the chilla so before we go into this
I wanted to give a quick thank you to
everyone who kept who continued their
pledge throughout patreon last month or
was a new member of the patreon
community thank you guys so much for all
your support over there as a matter of
fact we're going to do another patron of
the day shout out for Jeff bearskin
Peterson gem at the end of this video so
Jeff if you're watching stay tuned my
friend oh yeah and if you're not stay
tuned and see what they're like all
right maybe you want one maybe you want
one
[Music]
look
[Music]
I'm funky on there except the kids we
got a bit too shorter very favors don't
[ __ ] me on there I'm working with some
of the country's finest subs and of
course young Mozart and go-kart over
there great thanks robbery story so
let's give them something bold and blue
to talk about what's akela
[Music]
[Music]
aren't you the lucky one that's right
[Music]
[Music]
whoa damn right names attract oh man
[Music]
you just want he just wants to be David
Ayer and just with all the soundtracks
is good and then you know I was just
reading a thing this afternoon that said
like if there's one thing Edgar Wright
knows maybe better than movies it's
music and from having seen all the
having seen all of his movies and even
space I believe yeah yeah you know I
gotta say just for just for a trailer
the way they included all the quotes
from the critics was really awesome yeah
that was like a stylish trailer then I
thought a lot of credit goes to the
creators of the trailer for how they
included the text how they were smiling
stylishly infused it throughout the
whole thing
yeah it was a nice nice trailer nicely
done guys that's the thing is that it
almost reminded me of watching like a
Tony Scott movie or something yeah like
where the words pop up but not as
annoying yeah yeah as they say I am so
excited I'm gonna do first go for it I
know we talked about it at another video
we covered a lot of it the things that I
got more excited for this time around
that we did we didn't hone in on before
what is Jamie Foxx he looks like he's
having a ball of a time oh yeah this is
a cast of actors who really know the
tone of the film they're in you could
just tell there's a specific energy and
styles of the performances just from the
trailer alone I'm confident to say that
it is the
100% rotten tomatoes and pretty sure is
Edgar Wright has we already know what
Edgar Wright is like working with
different actors yeah when he always
pulls together a gray on someone this is
not like the biggest thing I left this
trailer with is like I can't wait to see
this ensemble yeah because there are
some terrific actors and actors I wasn't
even I didn't remember where it's like I
remembered Jamie Foxx and Jon Hamm and
Ansel Elgort and all them but Kevin
Spacey and Jon Bernthal nail and Isaac
ins Ollis I've seen the first three
seasons up from dusk till dawn I didn't
really care for the first season but she
really grew on me in the second season
actually and I'm excited for her to be
in a role outside of that show because I
don't know familiar with anything else
you've done other than from dusk till
dawn
I mean looks like she kicked some
serious ass I love any moment in a movie
where they reload assault rifles herself
yeah he guns in any fashion that that's
always cool especially the high citizen
areas one of me I'm excited she's in a
movie like this that you know had yeah a
good pedigree you know it's like it's
hard to make the transition necessarily
from TV to the movies and this seems
like a great vehicle done intended for
her so she looks like a standout female
character in this film
yeah and it's exciting to see Jamie
Foxx's in a really fun role I mean I
know he's done his comedy bits and
movies like horrible losses and yeah but
a ticket is fun and bad and fun and a -
yeah at the same time like this is the
right role I feel for Jamie Foxx to be
in what's the guys it was for you - Zane
I give a like on adel cancel pencil
absol I go on ansel elgort damn it oh
good man I'm really so for this guy zoom
I think I think if this film is a big
hit he could be a huge star from this
one or it can be like the first film
this is we made of things Chris Pratt is
Xactimate they were like oh now we could
get to later bird [ __ ] some more movies
down and they based on only looking hey
I'm happy for him man I mean Italy he's
popped up and stuff tonight it's weird
like I saw him in the kinds of movies
that just weren't necessarily for me
he's always at least been pretty good
like that wasn't good so I'm excited to
see him you know in a starring role like
this and also that I Drive a lot and
listen to music so I just you know I
feel like I will probably resonate with
this gift and Drive has I mean a big
influence of the movie drive was the
getaway driver the heist
yeah and he loves music yeah and this is
the Edgar Wright style their dad
Nicholas Mahan resin version of that
scenario and now there's the Edgar
Wright scenario this you'll have like
the really stylized like almost laconic
program and then this one will be like
the really verbose like witty like hyper
energy but like super components that's
the thing about Edgar Wright is Edgar
Wright has a handle on kinetic energy in
a way that isn't like getting beaten
around the head and neck no it's like
it's kinetic but it's really composed
yeah that's a think it's more than just
being in the editing room and probably
owing crazy stuff while you're editing
it seems like he has it all mapped out
while he's filming it and then he puts
it together in the editing room he's one
of those filmmakers who like whenever I
hear his name or I see any of his movies
I feel like he is one of the most
composed filmmakers working right now
yeah like the compositions of his movies
are down to the last oh yeah oh no and
nothing is thrown away in an a great
movie that I've seen so far he's he's
yet to make a bad film I haven't seen
this so it's not my personal paint on
baby Trevor this is the bold move say it
a hundred percent Roger yeah it's gonna
be someone who's like oh my kitty kitty
99% media they don't probably be Armand
white again a butcher all right well
yeah baby driver can't wait to see this
movie we're going to be going okay night
no doubts about that we are going
opening night no questions asked John
shut up or doing it the fault in our
cars yeah subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell John is dat
John Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
and like I said early patron of the day
shout out for Jeff bearskin Peterson you
know Jeff bearskin I I would love to
have some Jeff skin I like Jeff skin
right off all your flesh your epidermis
and just wear it and go out like EU you
know like a like a Devil's Rejects thing
but with the whole body
i Leatherface thing but the whole baja
just get a jet skin going on I think
Jeff would love that I think that would
be a real honor I mean if somebody
wanted to wear my skin I would be a
little bit honor
yeah Jeff if you increase your pledge by
five dollars more I will personally kill
we will Flay you I will kill you it I
will skin you with love and respect love
and respect is all out of you know
everything and feeling free force and
appreciation plus then you'll get to
watch baby driver with us because you'll
be you'll be there let's go always be
there always that's what we're going to
do we're going to we're going to like
hot glue your skin right on the Griggs
been a while since I skinned someone oh
yeah I feel like Justin next got to do
it aren't you glad you signed up this is
what the shoutouts or all of that what
it's all people this what you're missing
on